is he a narcissist a sociopath a
psychopath
all of those things none of them I don't
think that he's a psychopath
um because
he's been successful in repeated
Enterprises over long periods of time
and he has a variety of people who are
remain intensely loyal to him it's very
easy to demonize someone that you don't
approve of let's say and certainly Trump
is being subject I would say to more
demonization than any political leader
in the west that I can remember in my
entire lifetime including Richard Nixon
would you like him to run again would it
be good for America do you think if I
had my druthers and I say this I hope
with due care I would rather see someone
like DeSantis step forward who shares
some of that forthright
strength let's say that characterizes
Trump at his best but seems to be a more
uh cautious administrator and a less
divisive figure I can't believe I do it
with the guy he's that good